the Philadelphia Police Department has
taken 72 officers off the street because
of social media posts described as
racist sexist and violent they were
recently revealed by a watchdog group
that revealed thousands opposed from
police officers around the country
Errol Barnett is in Philadelphia where
the announcement was made just yesterday
Errol what are the consequences of these
officers may face well Tony we're about
to find out the police commissioner here
says that none of the 72 officers
involved in all of this have been
punished just yet but he does expect
several dozen of them will be they'll
face consequences which could include
dismissal meanwhile the Philly PD and
you see the headquarters behind me is
conducting its own internal review of
some 3,000 social media posts that may
violate department policy all the issues
that we have to deal with this is one we
certainly could have done without
Philadelphia Police Commissioner Richard
Ross is taking action nearly three weeks
after the release of thousands of
offensive social media posts allegedly
linked to more than 300 officers in his
department
72 officers have been placed in
administrative duty it really makes me
sick because we are in a position to
know better
earlier this month a team of lawyers and
activists with the Plainview Project
revealed their findings after
painstakingly reviewing the Facebook
pages of 3,500 current and former police
officers in eight departments from
Arizona to Florida to Philadelphia one
user rights it's a good day for a
chokehold don't feel like playing with
the animals tonight rights another and a
third post an image that says death to
Islam protesters in Philadelphia have
been demanding the city take action for
weeks this attorney point because they
felt the license to engage in
in in a public way according to its
social media policy the Philadelphia
Police Department prohibits profanity
personal insults and discriminatory
material we will not be shy about
meeting out the appropriate discipline
we need to get it right for the
community that looks to us for
protection and guidance
I mean you effectively have faith in the
police versus First Amendment rights the
president of the Philly police union
released a statement saying quote it's
premature and irresponsible for the
Commissioner to tell the public that
police officers will be fired without a
complete investigation and moving
forward the department here will
institute anti bias training but I spoke
with the woman behind Plainview its
executive director told me that
investigations are now underway in all
eight police jurisdictions her group
studied Anthony Errol Barnett in
Philadelphia thanks Errol